let's do a few more examples of finding
the limit of functions as X approaches
infinity or negative infinity so here I
have this crazy function 9 X to the
seventh minus 17 X to the 6 plus 15
square roots of X all of that over 3x to
the seventh plus 1000 X to the fifth
minus log base two of X so what's going
to happen as X approaches infinity and
the key here like we've seen in other
examples is just to realize which terms
will dominate so for example in the
numerator out of these three terms the 9
X to the seventh is going to grow much
faster than any of these other terms so
this is the dump do not this is the
dominating term in the numerator and the
denominator 3x to the seventh it's going
to grow much faster than an X to the
fifth term I'm not definitely much
faster than a log base 2 term so at
infinity as we get closer and closer
infinity this function is going to be
rough it's going to be roughly equal to
9 X to the seventh over 3x to the
seventh and so we can say especially
since as we get larger and larger as we
get closer and closer to infinity these
two things are going to get closer and
closer to each other we can say this
limit is going to be the same thing as
this limit which is going to be equal to
the limit as X approaches infinity well
we can just cancel out the X to the 7 so
it's going to be 9 thirds or just 3
which is just going to be 3 so that is
our limit as X approaches infinity of
all of this craziness now let's do the
same with this function over here once
again crazy function we're going to
negative infinity but the same
principles apply which terms which terms
dominate as the absolute value of x get
larger and larger and larger as X gets
larger in magnitude well in the
numerator
it's the 3x to the third term in the
denominator it's the 6 X to the fourth
term so this is going to be the same
thing as the limit of 3 X to the third
over 6 X to the fourth as X approaches
negative infinity and if we simplify
this this is going to be equal to the
limit as X approaches negative infinity
of 1 over 2 X and what's this going to
be well if the denominator even though
it's becoming a larger and larger and
larger negative number it becomes one Oh
or a very very large negative number
which is going to get us pretty darn
close to zero just as one over X as X
approaches negative infinity gets us
close to zero so this right over here
the horizontal asymptote in this case is
y is equal to zero and I encourage you
to graph it or try it out with numbers
to verify that for yourself the key
realization here is to simplify the
problem by just thinking about which
terms are going to dot which terms are
going to dominate the rest now let's
think about this one what is the limit
of this crazy function as X approaches
infinity
well once again what are the dominating
terms in the numerator it's 4 X to the
fourth and the denominator is 250 X to
the third these are the highest degree
terms so this is going to be the same
thing as the limit as X approaches
infinity of 4 X to the fourth over 200
over 250 250 X to the third which is
going to be the same thing as the limit
of let's see 4 well I could just read
this is going to be the same thing as we
could divide 200 in well I'll just leave
it like this it's going to be the limit
of 4 over 250 X to the fourth divided by
X 2/3 just x times X as X approaches
infinity or we could even say this is
going to be for 250 it's for 250 it's
times the limit as X approaches infinity
of X now what's this what's the limit of
X as X approaches infinity what is just
going to keep growing what forever so
this is just going to be this right over
here is just going to be infinity
infinity times some number right over
here is going to be infinity so the
limit as X approaches infinity of all of
this it's actually unbounded its
infinity and a kind of obvious way of
seeing that right from the get-go is to
realize that the numerator is has a
fourth degree term while the highest
degree term in the denominator is only a
3rd degree term so the numerator is
going to grow far faster than the
denominator so the numerator is growing
far faster than far faster than the
denominator you're going to approach
infinity in this case if the numerator
is going far if the numerator is going
far slower than the denominator if the
denominator is going far faster than the
numerator like this case
you're then approaching zero so
hopefully find that a little bit useful